[Music]
so we are right in the middle of our
Network meeting all those wonderful
people came here to talk with us about
the building science weekend to get to
know each other and us as a team and
this is a continuation from our
information session this morning which
we held online and now really happy to
have everybody here with us in the
office I definitely recommend joining
belisa swing you can grab different
ideas you could have a great exchange
with mind-blowing
experts uh who we knew scientists in the
field and also just visitors who could
inspire you with their questions it is
not just about science but about the way
science is communicated which is usually
what scientists are struggling with
because it's very nice he has to do
science but it's also very nice to be
able to communicate it to the general
public Berlin science week it's a great
space
to make a networking between researchers
of different parts of the world and we
opened the doors of the Mexican embassy
for those that are interesting in
knowing the results of the cooperation
of the scientific relation between
Mexico and Germany It's always important
to bring Society science and art
together yeah looking for a good
co-creations we're also discussing
whether we could actually extend our
partnership into more creative exploring
ways of bringing Arts and Science
communities together
we're just collecting the program right
now we have already quite some
submissions but still more to come
hopefully from all of you so please talk
to us
[Music]